[Aplausos]
[Música]
hola a todos gracias por estar aquí
quién y más por tomarse el tiempo de
escuchar son 15 minutos y ya empezaron
nunca ha dado una conferencia tan corta
creo que para mí es un reto para ellos y
para todos los que se sientan para
nahyan decir qué es esto es un gran
logro gracias colegio americano por
invitarme y gracias a eugenia eres un
genio por tenerme aquí bueno yo nací en
saltillo coahuila aquí al lado
me fui a la ciudad de mexico estudié en
la universidad anáhuac el norte y la
verdad es que no sabía que quería ser de
grande sólo sabía que quería
fue de excepcional en lo que fuera
en el peak de mi carrera cuando era
falla un editor de la revista del méxico
cuando yo estaba sentada en el desfile
de chanel y dior al mismo tiempo me
enamoré y la reguera no la regué tanto
porque pues el amor siempre soy bonito
pero con un plan de casarme y con
vestido colgado pues me quedé embarazada
y fue yo que es la primera vez que lo
digo ay es que es un poquito como duro
pero es importante que las chavas lo
sepan y para mí fue muy importante
entender que yo sólo tenía dos opciones
mientras el chico con el que lo tuve que
era mi novio y con el que viene a casar
tenía cien un era correr otra hacerse
loco o traer a los echarse el paquete
bueno y yo sólo tenía dos opciones mejor
dicho las mujeres normalmente tienen dos
opciones tener a un bebé o no tenerlo
pero para mí sólo había una opción
tenerla así me educaron y
si hoy pudiera de ser el tiempo lo
volvería a ser una y mil veces
y se fue obviamente se sobra decirlo
cuando te embarazas
te enseñan a que pues hay que ver para
adelante y que uno no se puede detener
ni hacer víctima ni a dar lástima ni a
pedir dinero a sus papás eso fue lo que
a mí me enseñaron y gracias a eso
aprendí que
que yo estaba renaciendo no solo mi bebé
estaba naciendo sino que yo estaba
renaciendo
en mi oficina sentía que todos querían
como verme destruida de alguna forma yo
era la editorial más importante del país
y había muchas envidias y yo decía que
raro pues si tener un bebé siempre es
una bendición porque a la gente le gusta
verme con lástima y yo lo notaba pero mi
familia sólo me apoyaba y me daba todo
el amor para que yo siguiera adelante en
una cosa increíble yo decía bueno pues
ya tengo 31 años tampoco es algo tan
grave y al contrario como queda algo que
yo siempre había deseado y simplemente
dios el destino y la vida me lo estaba
poniendo antes de tiempo
tomar la tomada la decisión de tener un
bebé hermoso tenía la opción de la
venganza y dije pues lo voy a quemar en
redes sociales y es el momento perfecto
aunque no habían tantas redes sociales
pero mi educación una vez más me entra
diciendo me dijo no hables del tema es
muy poco elegante si quiera decir su
nombre y decidí llevarlo en silencio
toda mi vida
y
uno piensa para que hacer ciertas cosas
que puedan revelar la verdad la verdad
de otros y en este caso yo pensaba para
que en el amor y la educación del alma y
la elegancia del alma
uno no puede mandar sobre los demás uno
es responsable de sus propios actos pero
no de los actos de los demás así que yo
tenía que seguir adelante y adelante y
adelante yo aquí era la editora de la
revista ella tomó una medalla sentada
janet pero al mismo tiempo mi corazón
estaba destrozado
es difícil hablar de esto perdón es que
es importante que lo sepan
todo esto hacía más pronta mi maternidad
y qué dolor y qué humillación yo sentía
todo el tiempo pero al mismo tiempo
estaba viviendo en el mundo de los más
privilegiados de las que están en todos
los desfiles de los que todo mundo
aplauden de las personas que van y la
gente le dice que fregona eres y cómo
has logrado todo pero yo por adentro no
podía ni respirar
pero qué oportunidad de renacer muchas
personas pueden tirarse y decir aquí se
acabó y muchas otras como yo que siguen
luchar y deciden irse con todo y contra
todo y como debe ser con orgullo y con
honor y trabajando
no creo que se me olvidará
no podía seguir viviendo en la burbuja
en la primera fila en cualquier desfile
del mundo ya no era lógico no era
congruentes no podía yo estar fingiendo
algo que al mismo tiempo cuando yo
llegaba a mi realidad era como y ahora
que con que pago el departamento que
quiero dejarle a mi hijo cuando crezca
y decía en la mesa pues ahora sí que me
toca ponerme la pila y voy a empezar a
hacer mis empresas porque el mismo
trabajo te cuesta trabajar para una
revista de moda que hacer tu propia tu
propia industria
y lo que sí tenía claro era que quería
ayudar a méxico y que quería ayudar a
los diseñadores mexicanos sabía que con
el concurso que había inventado ya nos
había ayudado bastante los puse en
portadas los hice muy ricos a muchos a
otros los ponía en posiciones increíbles
pero yo donde estaba y donde estaba mi
futuro como empresario después me casé
las cosas nuevo no no pintan tan mal me
casé dure cuatro años y tuve a mi
segunda bebé cita pues casualmente y la
vida te lleva
llevando te va llevando como por otros
caminos y otra vez me quedé sola pero
ahora la responsabilidad se hizo por vos
algo que aprendí de mi mamá y que me
molestaba tanto cuando lo veía y me
decía jamás en tu vida por ningún hombre
dejes tus sueños
jamás dejes de trabajar en ellos porque
no importa con quién te cases yo ya
había tenido tres anillos de compromiso
no importa si es una persona de la
realeza lo cual es la verdad no importa
si es con el amor de tu vida con el
cambio a casa y tuve un bebé y no
importa quién sea tú nunca dejes de
hacer lo tuyo porque nunca sabes lo que
va a pasar
yo soy mamá cállate no me gusta oír que
digas eso hoy pasa el tiempo y digo qué
razón tenía qué hubiera pasado si yo lo
hubiera no le hubiera hecho caso y
hubiera dejado todo por el primero donde
estaría ahorita y si hubiera dejado todo
por el segundo dónde estaría ahorita
teniendo que por dejar mis sueños y
entonces decidí que mi mamá era la mujer
más sabia del mundo y entendí que uno
como mujer nunca puede dejar sus sueños
de lado jamás por ningún hombre por
ninguna circunstancia y menos forzadas
creo que es súper importante que que uno
nos quiera dejar porque era ser una
familia es súper válido pero cuando su
carrera está a punto de de edificarse
nunca antes esa es mi vida
[Aplausos]
para nada quiero decir que está en
desventaja y en dolor te hace más fuerte
porque entonces volvemos a hacer
víctimas todos lo que sí quiero decir es
que
al parecer la desventaja para muchos es
algo que es contrario a ti pero que
creen para mí sólo fue una aliada fue
una palanca para crecer más y más jamás
vi el dolor ni la humillación ni la
tristeza como un puente para salir para
abajo sino lo vi para saltar hacia donde
más pudiera jamás me deje caer y fue una
cosa que de verdad cuesta mucho trabajo
hoy tengo 12 empresas de las cuales las
12 facturan muchísimo una o dos ahí van
caminando las demás son increíblemente
exitosas tengo tiendas tengo el sitio de
ecommerce tengo proyectos que están
levantando a méjico y llevándolo a lo
más alto en lo que se puede percibir
nuestro país con los creativos mexicanos
con la gente que realmente hace bien las
cosas y todo porque por miedo con la
gente dice no tengas miedo no si ten
miedo ten mucho miedo porque el miedo te
hace sacar las alas para volar si tú no
sientes miedo jamás vas a saber de lo
que eres capaz
la gente que siempre vive en ventaja a
veces me da tristeza porque pienso nunca
saber lo que es tener hambre y tener
tanto miedo que te hace levantar noche
que son cosas que sobre las mujeres que
tienen hijos me pueden entender y son
cosas que solo las mujeres con mucha
garra pueden entender cuando uno está en
una situación donde sobrevives o te
mueres
cuando la gente como mensaje la revista
del domingo decía pero como si acaso
estuviera jean paul gaultier es el éxito
de cualquier programa de televisión y yo
es justo el momento porque uno no puede
vivir engañado con espejismos el único
la única forma en la que uno puede
lograr éxito es trabajando el instagram
hace que todos nos confundamos ver
mujeres que llegan tan rápido al éxito y
pensar que que fácil no gana cuánto
dinero y en cuánto tiempo se hizo famosa
eso es uno de ameal o de a millones el
verdadero éxito viene con trabajo y con
muchos escalones que hay que pasar y
sólo habiendo pasado todos estos
escalones uno lo pueden lograr no hay
salidas rápidas ni short cuts para el
éxito sólo el trabajo y de paso a paso
hoy tengo 40 años me estoy quitando uno
pero esos 40 años yo empecé a trabajar a
los 18 y hasta ahorita empiezo a ver la
luz cuando más desesperada me sentía
decía es que ya di todo lo que tenía que
dar y otro desaparece una sorpresa para
entender que lo bueno apenas venía de
verdad
después de 20 años uno empieza a ver que
si se puede
quisiera decirle a las mujeres que jamás
jamás
dejen sus sueños de lado por nadie que
nunca permitan que la educación
latinoamericana nos haga pensar que la
única forma de ser reconocidas es
estando cerca de alguien no hay nada
mejor que hacer una pareja con un hombre
que respeta lo que tú eres que te empuja
a ser mejor
eso es el verdadero amor no la gente que
te pisa para que tú no seas exitoso no
la gente que te quiere ver humillada eso
no es amor amor verdadero es cuando
alguien quiere una familia contigo y te
levanta y hasta te te anuncia como
posible candidata para la presidencia
obama hillary clinton las mujeres de
verdad y los hombres de verdad y las
parejas reales son las que se empujan
unos a los otros lo que un empuja a otro
hacia abajo para que el otro brille esa
es la verdad la verdadera situación en
méxico y en el mundo ya no se vale estar
abajo de ellos ni tampoco arriba de
ellos se vale hacer equipo
no se confundan por favor jamás mujeres
se confundan en que es el momento en que
todas tenemos que tener estos derechos
de trabajar de ser reconocidas no es que
sea un derecho es que es lo que toca
hacer desde que nacimos y creo que haber
hecho a lograr encontrar aún es lo
suficientemente inteligentes y seguros
de sí mismos para poder crecer en este
mundo es nuestra mayor labor
quiero decirles que después de tantos
años y de tanto caer lo único que puedo
decir es que mis grandes fracasos han
hecho que mis grandes logros sean
posibles jamás en mi vida imaginaría a
mi misma parada hoy aquí haciendo un
sector si no hubiera sufrido tanto
si no me hubieran dado tan duro como
para sacar las alas deciden si es quien
soy donde estoy no no puede serlo si no
sufre un poquito
si se pueden evitar el sufrimiento qué
bueno qué elevados sean todos pero si
toca sufrir véalo como la oportunidad
más grande de crecer y de ser alguien
porque de verdad no hay de otra no hay
otra no hay otra opción la vida nos da
un shot una oportunidad para ser
excepcionales y en nuestro país y en
nuestra cultura desafortunadamente
primero hay que quitarnos de un gran
peso de encima para lograrlo pero no
importa lo importante es que sepamos
llevar el equilibrio ser mamá ser una
business muy humana estar presente con
tus hijos y ser amorosos y lograr que
sean amorosos darles todo el amor y al
mismo tiempo que tus empresas fluyan y
al mismo tiempo tener una pareja todo se
puede todo se puede nada de que uno
tiene que escoger o eres feliz hoy es
exitoso nana no se puede todo se puede
tener hijos se puede ser exitoso se
puede tener empresas se puede tener
hijos educados y sanos todo se puede el
cielo es el límite nadie tiene derecho a
limitarnos
entonces con este toque y con estas
palabras quiero cerrar mis quince
minutos diciéndoles que si yo pude todas
pueden gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]